fährt gerade die harley davidson truppe
hier direkt aus amerika vorbei
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge vom megabyte kurz
kontrollieren ob alles anders so fraps
es an auch das sind die läuft kamera
läuft endlich wieder facetime hier am
start nachdem es glaube ich sechs oder
fünf partien drehte ich jetzt mach ich
dich hier so zack da bin ich ich habe
haare nicht gemacht ganz einfach ich
habe gleich einen friseurtermin deswegen
dachte ich haye kommt nehme ich jetzt
noch mal paar folgen mit der alten
frisur auf beziehungsweise nicht alte
frisur ich hab einfach greift geduscht
und meine haare sind einfach nur total
cup immer nach dem duschen
ich hoffe aber das stört ich muss man
ganz gut ihm ein kabel also ihr seht
jetzt hier alles hier so ein bisschen
behalten
damit ist stativ nicht genau auf dem
kabel der ding steht der maus ich werde
gleich mal ganz kurz am fenster im
hintergrund zu machen weil ich denke
eine menge
fährt gerade die harley davidson truppe
hier direkt aus amerika vorbei sind echt
egal ich hoffe ihr lasst euch davon
jetzt nicht zu beeindrucken von mir spaß
ich möchte mich wieder eine menge mit
fiete wies beschäftigen und wie riecht
paket mal ganz kurz meine jetpack weg
weil das liegt doch ein bisschen auf
wenn man die ganze zeit so hoch springt
ich möchte erstmal ganz kurz was zu der
neuen regelung sagen ganz kurz man hier
den ton lauter machen
die 69 die neue regelungen die wir
eingeführt haben simon und dehner und
weiteren dazwischen videos gemacht
es wird in zukunft so ablaufen dass man
täglich 30 minuten hochladen darf
natürlich davon hat täglich neun stunden
folge bringen allerdings müssten danach
die beiden tage entweder nur 15 minuten
kommen oder halt den takt an bei ein tag
pause
wenn man darf quasi in sieben tagen also
sprich in einer woche darf man halt
höchstens dementsprechend 7 x 30 minuten
machen
sieben mal 30 sind dabei sind
dreieinhalb stunden
dreieinhalb stunden hat man höchstens in
der woche hochladen
das ist das was bagso in der letzten
zeit so alles in einem tag gemacht hat
das ist einfach damit wir alle auf einen
standard kommt hört auf ihr zu helfen
bevor jetzt den daumen runter button
drückt macht das bei simon entspannt
sieht man macht das bei gar keinen das
bringt nichts wir haben die regel so
festgelegt dass es besser und alle die
jetzt mit einer besseren regelungen
ankommen die wird nicht besser sein das
ist die beste regelung damit spark immer
noch weiterhin was hochladen kann legt
nämlich jetzt in nächster zeit erstmals
einen ganzen stapel hoch weil bei spark
ist zum beispiel jetzt irgendwie vor
einer woche die folge gekommen die bei
mir schon vor vier wochen gekommen ist
und das war einfach ein riesen
unterschied den spark verursacht hat
dadurch dass er immer weiter aufgenommen
hat auf dem server in seiner art sucht
zustand gefallen verfallen ist was hat
er da gebaut achte sind nach menschen
beschäftigt sich auch schon mit der
experte das ja schön wenn nachbar
ja ich werde weiterhin einer
solarenergie links festhalten wir noch
ein paar solarpanels machen bzw sind
dieser folge werde ich mich ein bisschen
mit den kommentaren beschäftigen also
noch mal kurz um zu der regelung zu
sprechen zu kommen
da oben es partner was der alles noch
baut das ist doch heftig na gut
spark wird jetzt erst mal einen ganzen
stapel hochladen zu schnell sind wie
möglich und danach wird spart täglich
nur ein paar hochladen dürfen der 15
minuten geht oder halt 27 minuten aber
das ist dumm und wir dürfen dann 30
minuten täglich hochladen
beziehungsweise 35,3 papst dann nach
zwölf minuten einfach damit wieder
langsam wieder ins park ausschließen
weil sonst werden sachen die wir geplant
haben die zum beispiel in hunger games
battle auf der map wollten wir mal
machen
das wird nicht funktionieren weil es war
einfach viel zu weit vorne wäre und ja
deswegen haben wir diese regelung
eingeführt glaube ich hoffe ihr nehmt
das jetzt nicht alles ganz so ernst es
ist quasi wie vorher nur das bak weniger
hochlädt ist nicht so schlimm
könnt ihr bei den anderen gucken
beziehungsweise die alten folgen gucken
mal erlebt jetzt täglich 5 45 folgen
hoch von daher ist auch egal
mir wurde eine menge kommentar
geschrieben und wie ihr wisst bin ich
aktiver kommentare lesern nicht immer
hier sagen höre like dass damit er sieht
ich lese dass wirklich alles wenn du
guter kommentat doch schon von alleine
gleich und zwar werde ich wahrscheinlich
warten jetzt mal ganz kurz die stadt pec
drauf ich werde erstmal solar hell
machen den werd ich mir dann aufsetzen
der lebt mich dann immer auf mit
solarenergie das immer mein jetpack
gefüllt ist das hier sind übrigens
longford boots egal wie hoch ich fliege
immer wenn ich runter darunter falle ich
krieg keinen fall schaden das ist immens
geil
danke an allen die da gegeben
ich glaube dass park einigen oder kev
ich weiß es nicht mehr
ich werde zu machen dass ich dieses feld
hier verkleinern werde und mir hier mein
haus zu bauen werde also da so drum und
das dann so quasi als atrium wird es
glaube ich in den kommentaren genannt
als so kleiner wintergarten vielleicht
kennen dass einige ich bin leider nicht
so viel battlefield hab bisher glaube
ich 20 stunden spielzeit und das letzte
mal gespielt vor weil sich fünf sechs
monaten jedenfalls werde gibt es auch
einen kleinen raum bei den neuen karten
beim neuen map pack ich hab mir damals
premium geholt das macht sie mon 810
will seinen gras nach oben holen
das ist cool gab es von map pack und
zwar ganz einfach da gab es einen raum
dabei sollen da kommt man so unter gehen
dann kommt man im pool der
tiefergelegten ebene sowie touren
dauerhaft mehr in dieser raum da wo
diese chillen und so was wollte ich in
die richtung aufmachen
ganz kurz hier kurz noch mal wechseln
ich habe irgendwann hält mit wasser
steht verzaubert das heißt wenn ich
jetzt ins wasser gehen kann nicht immer
ganz kurz zeigen im brunnen zum beispiel
das heißt ich bin länger unter wasser
aber das kennen die meist wahrscheinlich
schon
ich halte weiter meine solar kann man
jetzt gehen schalter gehen springen wird
gestoppt oder den morgen ging's punkten
gefallen ihr seht ihr ich kann länger
hat man also das geht da schon echt
langsam weg die bürger bleibt der film
das megaprojekt stadt wohnen man hätte
diese spezies die einfach in so einem
tollen weiß nich energy dosen rolla ein
diamant ist weg wurden die geklaut oder
ich weiß es nicht
mir wird wohl erst mal quatschen ihr mir
wird vorgeworfen hat dass bei denen
gesehen mit dem reaktor dings ich möchte
ja nichts kaputt machen möchte eine
gucken habe ich mich da einfach nur das
selbst angucken hier unten nichts
anfassen eltern haften für conny passt
ihm nicht passt ja nix an die möchte
dass nur an kuchen und zwar wird da in
den kommentaren gegen mich gehetzt und
wurde gesagt du hast starstürmer geklaut
so her was für türme oder wird er noch
geschrieben du hast was gegen stuck ich
sehe was habe ich dagegen spark auch
hier ist das reaktor scheiße da gehe ich
mal lieber weg also habe das bei denen
einem video gesehen wie er sich da
gefreut hat darüber mit den schönen
glasfaserkabeln ihre schnelle energie
na gut ich werde jetzt mal weg hin fick
dich alter ich möchte nichts kaputt
machen ich wollte jetzt ein schreiben
hdf dna war darf ich ja nicht na gut ich
möchte jetzt aber auch nicht die ganze
und ich jetzt die ganze zeit angucken
was das denn ach so zornig meint ja dann
macht das extra so herzlich damit alle
denken dass
damit wir uns alle auf regen so aber
egal kümmern wir uns um unsere sachen
und zwar wird es von mir jetzt erst mal
dieses guthaben
man darf ja wöchentlich oder täglich 30
minuten hochladen ich habe die erste die
ersten zwölf habe ich allerdings jeden
tag nur ein paar buchladen das heißt ich
habe jetzt quasi hier unten sind gleich
ob es egal wer das heißt es quasi 12
parts die ich noch so einfach hochladen
darf das heißt ich darf 12 12 tage 30 45
minuten hochladen
das heißt letztens am 30 53
danach weiß nicht wie ich das machen
werde weil heute ist der dreisteste 5
tobias aufnehme sieben minuten einfach
nur quatsch bisher aber muss jetzt
einfach mal gesagt werden
deswegen darf ich jetzt in der nächsten
zeit auf jeden fall ein paar mehr videos
hochladen also da dann bitte nicht
rummeckern so und zwar wenn ich mich um
ein paar kommentare wieder kümmern weil
ihr ja nur fleißig kommentiert libro
3000 konto hast neuen mini um scherben
mini umstadt 2
bro ich habe zwei damit kriegst du ein
minimum blabla mit haltbarkeit ja das
ist der mini um stein
wenn du das mit vier gold in die
werkbank legst kriegst du einen
diamanten ja ich weiß
wenn du diesen kommentar nicht versteht
es folgt ein fachkräfte den wir schon
sehen die man ja das hat ja auch schon
macht jetzt auch schon hier vier
diamanten woraus ich mir dann hier so
ein paar sachen gemacht habe danke dafür
habe ich schon gemacht der kommentar ist
auch schon länger da drin so was ist
euch das außerdem gleich null so darf
und zwar wo ich mich darum kümmern
wollte war ein solar helm
dafür brauche ich zwar ein solarpanel
und das ist total schwer zu machen
deswegen ich zeige euch das mal ganz
kurz solar helm habe ich schon am anfang
über gequasselt macht man übrigens warte
so oder so das heißt ein eisen helm zu
machen das relativ einfach ich glaub ich
hab sogar noch eine hier irgendwo damit
drin sein so dass noch ein einzelhändler
habe ich schon mal den parcours dahin
übrigens auch ich meine ja wenn ich ins
land rück ist es sortiert war aber so
möchte ich das nicht haben
so macht es auf jeden fall und dann
brauche ich noch dass hier solarpanel
kopper habe ich auch und solarpanel das
alles hinzukriegen was das habe ich auch
noch eine menge dass das hinzukriegen
das ist blöd weil ich brauche dafür
island furness der zeitlich relativ
einfaches blabla aber ich brauche halt
auch batterien
wenn ich jetzt ganz so toll und ich weiß
nicht brauche ich nicht was ich mache
nervig wie sonst was mit der kirche hier
so übrigens ach so ich nehme alleine auf
weil ich habe keine lust auf andere
dinge dazwischen quatschen
nein also kef hat mir da schon ich bin
dazwischen gequatscht nicht gegen kämpft
aber naja hatte das ist jetzt ein
elektronik circle was hab ich hier
elektronik sorgt okay gut nicht wir
können nur gold staffel bockig 2
jetzt ab
nein der jo davon habe ich zwei
generated wie vor liege kein habe ich
noch da brauche ich drei von uns nicht
benötige sie habe ich den samen dabei
eher gut
dafür brauche ich eine helm auf jeden
fall
kupferkabel 31 23
fünf eisen normale menge eisen 1 2 3 4 5
und alben voll das habe ich bleibe oder
nicht mehr so ganz kurzer entfernung
bei solchen sachen fest kennen ist das
unnötigste was es gibt weil ich einfach
nur für bildschirm gucken dass ein akku
verschwendung
aber egal way nicht lernfähig guckt dass
er übrig einmal das er übrigens der
nächsten folge holt das brauche ich drei
und drei glas 123 für mich meint auch
allem die items normal raus luca sonst
kriegst du keine erfahrungen ich bin so
klug 23
ich habe alles nach hierfür den generate
habe ich noch drei rennen und der
batterie auch eine batterie mensch leute
diese batterien
ich mache jetzt einfach schon total viel
ich brauche tin tin redstone kopper
cable
redstone koffer cable leute das wird
eine richtige batterie orgie die ich
jetzt hier machen will
da 16 batterien soll das reicht das
macht lockt so redstone wieder rein
körperbildes wird nacht das gute ist ich
bin gerade einzige auf dem server das
heißt wenn ich pendle wilder mann oh
mann was offenbar fast über mein handy
gewollt dass günther noch die fahne der
regen sofort wieder auf und der sound
geht auf wenn es regnet gerade das heißt
ich kann auch jetzt pennen gehn das
weidlich für minecraft geplant endlich
kann man gehen wenn gewitter ist auch
ein gewitter ist deutschland
ich dachte ich muss genießen aber muss
ich doch nicht oder nur wenn's gewitter
ist wenn ihr da besseres wissen dann
chefs einfach in die kommentare
weil es ist total hätte ich würde am
liebsten kamera umdrehen oder dass der
fokus wieder komplett
von a mein leben ist so schrecklich so
vor allem klausurphase ich nehm auf jolo
so also freunde solar erst mal die
batterien in 18 die feineren ach so
deswegen braucht dich die höhe muss ich
gar nicht mehr so da mit den generator
und jetzt so werden die glaube ich
angeordnet
das soll die elektronik star kids oder
sich ein solarpanel kommt hier der
hellen
dabei kompatibel los kommt schon
cancellara toller brücken die
wasserqualität der jetzt gar nix los
wird na gut aber egal ich habe solar
helm das heißt wenn ich jetzt meinen
jetpack habe ihr seht dass ich hab's an
und es wird die ganze zeit aufgeladen
einfach weil gerade tag ist auch wenn
ich fliege
kurz es wird weiterhin aufgeladen das
heißt ich fliege jetzt zum beispiel mit
28.300 hoch vielleicht nicht dass ich
unbedingt da allerdings london nach
20.300 hoch 27 600 wieder auf dem boden
bleibt es einfach ein bisschen stehen
sich immer weiter hinauf das ist
eigentlich sehr sehr geil
nur ich mag es nicht jedes jetpack die
ganze anzug haben deswegen weiß nicht ob
der helme unbedingt so viel bringt ich
muss halt einfach nur nachher diese
reisen beiden schutz dingsbums die muss
ich mir aus diamanten machen weil sonst
habe ich fast gar keine rüstung sonst
bin ich einfach nur verzaubert aber die
dieses jet pack bringt auf jeden fall
eine menge denn creator wegfliegen